From Crypto King to criminal suspect
Sam Bankman-Fried's
stunning fall
has just gotten worse for him
this morning.
Federal authorities in New York
are expected to unseal the indic
that led to his arrest Monday
in the Bahamas.
The 30 year old founder of the f
crypto exchange
is set to appear in a Bahamian c
today.
He was supposed to testify
before Congress today
to explain his company's
sudden implosion.
Remember, the once billionaire l
his entire fortune
in just a matter of days?
When we get straight
now to CNN's Christine Romans.
She's here with more.
Christine, good morning to you.
He was supposed to testify
and then now this.
So what exactly happened?
Just an amazing fall from grace
and so many people wondering
where their money is.
Instead of
testifying before Congress, he's
facing an initial court
appearance in the Bahamas this m
Just a stunning fall from someon
who is once considered crypto's
golden boy
Sam Bankman-fried, the embattled
and former
CEO of the cryptocurrency giant
arrested in the Bahamas on Monda
after us
prosecutors filed
criminal charges against him.
U.S.
Attorney Damien Williams confirm
the arrest was based
on a sealed indictment
filed by the Southern District
of New York.
A person familiar
with the matter
tells The New York Times
the charges against the 30 year
former billionaire
include wire fraud,
wire fraud, conspiracy,
securities fraud,
securities fraud, conspiracy
and money laundering.
And the SEC is now saying
they, too, have authorized
separate charges
relating to his violations
of securities laws.
BANKMAN-FRIED was once considere
one of the most powerful figures
in crypto
before his company
suffered a liquidity crisis
and filed for bankruptcy last mo
leaving at least a million peopl
without access to their funds.
He has denied defrauding his cus
Once the dust has settled
and once all the
investigations have happened
that you won't be
arrested for fraud.
I don't think I will be.
I don't think that I,
I, I don't think
I tried to do anything wrong.
I don't know of
deposits being used to pay off
alameda creditors.
I didn't knowingly commit fraud.
I don't think I committed fraud.
I didn't want any of this to hap
I was certainly not nearly as co
as I thought I was.
The former
CEO teamed up with a slew of hig
celebrities and TV ads
and Super Bowl commercials
promoting crypto.
The key question for investigato
whether FedEx misappropriated
customer funds
when it made loans to BANKMAN-FR
hedge fund Alameda Research FCX.
His new CEO, John
Ray, paints a picture of a crypt
with virtually no corporate cont
And a shocking lack of financial
and other record keeping.
Ray, who is set to testify
today before the House
Financial Services Committee,
wrote in a prepared statement.
The collapse of RTX
is due to power left in the hand
of a very small group
of grossly
inexperienced
and unsophisticated individuals.
There was no person
who was chiefly in charge of
positional risk of customers on
And that feels pretty embarrassi
in retrospect.
Virtually no regulation,
absolutely no risk management,
and just the beginning of a lega
for BANKMAN-FRIED,
a representative
for him,
for his legal team
did not immediately respond
to CNN's request for comment
but it raises all kinds of quest
about where the money went
for these investors.
And remember, this is a platform
that was marketed
as a really easy entry level
way to get into crypto,
since regular people,
like all the mainstream
investors, could get into crypto
No one knows who that money is.
I'm so fascinated
by the fact that he's done
all these interviews recently
and despite his lawyers
telling him to basically be quie
I wonder how that's going to pla
into all of this.
I mean, there's all of this soun
explaining what he did and didn'
That will definitely play into t
I mean,
any lawyer would tell you, Shut
sit down, and we have to investi
what happened here with this com
But he is.
Even this weekend
he was talking to the BBC.
Let's discuss now.
Kara Swisher,
she's the host of the podcast
on Kara Swisher, thank you.
We appreciate you
joining us this morning.
Here's a question.
No, problem wasn't.
Weren't sure that there would be
because it's not regulated.
You know,
there was this whole back and fo
Were you surprised by this?
And it was just before
he was supposed to testify
in front of Congress, Kara.
No, I've been saying he's going
quite a bit.
I mean, it's fraud is fraud.
And, you know,
you can dress it up with crypto
and you can dress it up
with all kinds of saying,
I didn't know what was happening
but it's fraud.
And so I think it's a pretty
straightforward case for the gov
if they as long as they have
the proof that he was knowledgea
about what he was doing
and that he moved the money,
he can't just say he didn't know
Especially since he owned everyt
and was running everything
and and had this whole group of
in the Bahamas doing such.
I assume they have testimony
from others there,
but they
they wouldn't do this without so
that he knew what he was doing.
Hey, Carol.
Good morning.
I think it's your birthday soon
or it was so happy.
Happy, happy, blessed.
Thank you. But let me ask you ab
You say it's so well
and so clearly fraud is fraud.
No, matter
if it's dressed up with crypto.
But Gary Gensler,
the chair of the SEC, says
and this is a quote this morning
that Bankman-fried
built a house of cards
and a foundation of deception.
This comes in an environment
where none of those folks
regulate crypto,
which makes this easier to.
Go ahead.
I was going
to ask if does this lead
to some actual meaningful change
in terms of regulating this stuf
Well, they were beginning to reg
Remember, it's a nascent industr
and so they were starting to do
They had put all kinds of recomm
since the administration had don
Gary Gensler has talked about it
but they were just trying to dec
how to do that when this this ha
And so it still is an investor t
They still have existing laws
that they can use to apply to th
And, you know,
and I think
probably they got irritated
that he was going around
talking to everybody
and his mother about the situati
And so I think they you know,
they probably were like,
enough is enough.
Let's put him in jail.
It's not un similar
to Bernie Madoff
or many of the others
who have been convicted
of similar crimes.
Well,
that's what
stuck out to me
was just in recent days,
he was saying,
I don't think I'm going to get a
I don't think I'm going to be de
If I came to the United States,
because he's going to be testify
before a congressional hearing
today, but is set to do so over
And so I kind of wonder
how much damage,
all the media interviews,
all of them that he's been doing
could be in a factor on top of w
the allegations are that he's fa
Oh, absolutely.
He was just convicting himself
over and over and over again.
You know, and saying
he just
didn't think he was going to be
is exactly what you say
before you're arrested.
And so, you know, he has
his parents are law professors
at Stanford University
they certainly knew the stakes h
I think he was going
I called them
the unmade bed and pretending
he didn't know what was happenin
And these
this little boy
with he dresses up in shorts
and sort of mop the hair.
I think that's I, I don't know.
I just was sort of like
it seems like you are an adult
and you know what you were doing
But he was trying for that.
This sort of is it,
you know,
I found it disingenuous,
but he was trying for this. I do
I don't know where the money was
It was in the drawer here,
and someone must have taken it,
that kind of thing.
Alison, I remember after Madoff
like everyone was going to like
what were the warning signs?
Didn't people so many.
So let me ask you this, Kara,
because this
The New York Times is reporting,
know, this, it's called
Changpeng Zhao, who is
he's a crypto exchange,
finally head of a massive crypto
exchange, Binance.
He offered to save MDX,
but then he took a look at the b
and backed out of helping, sayin
I guess he saw issues.
So what could he have seen
that may have been a warning sig
And then the follow up is
should he have said something
or were people not listening
No.
I mean, it's not his job to do t
He probably saw leverage
upon leverage upon,
you know,
like lots of lots of warning sig
that they were borrowing back an
And, you know, there's other peo
like Carol and Alison,
who ran Alameda Research, this h
that BANKMAN-FRIED owns quite mo
I think, 90% of.
And so she was also
they were all tweeting this.
This is the thing.
They were all talking to each ot
in public,
which makes it even more interes
to my point, prosecution point o
That's my point.
Anyway, so
they're just leaving
they're like dropping climbing
all over the place.
I mean, that
they're listening
now is sort of interesting
to listen to the interviews.
Yeah, they are. They are.
All right.
Thank you, Carrie.
Thank you. Kara.
We'll see you soon.
We appreciate you waking up
really early for. Oh, no problem